hello internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message today
is march 18th in the year 2022 we are
live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv if you have not subscribed on
rumble mash the button for god's sakes
do i have to beg you people come on now
guys it's big day today because the
don't burn this book
no don't burn this country
i'm gonna have to get used to that i'm
really gonna have to get used to that
you can still buy doper in this book
which i highly recommend but don't burn
this country the book tour tickets have
gone on sale today so first off if you
want to just straight up order the book
you can do that at daverubin.combook
and the book is out on april 10th but
you can pre-order it right now but what
i really wanted to tell you is that the
tour tickets
are now for sale for the general public
do we have an image an image for that i
think we do we got something right uh
there you go people we're gonna be in
orlando west palm clearwater florida
raleigh north carolina atlanta georgia
chicago illinois dallas texas washington
dc right in the swamp west nyack new
york break california oxnard san jose
phoenix and denver colorado tickets are
on sale you can go to daverubin.com
events and at 10 a.m local time so east
coasters you can get them right now i
believe central time you can get them
west coast uh in an hour or two
and each show i'm going to give an hour
talk i promise every single show will be
different it'll sort of be loosely based
on the book but really what's on my mind
that day what's going on in the world
maybe i'll just go up with a newspaper
some days we we will see i'm gonna do
some more audience interaction i'm gonna
give some stuff away we're gonna do a q
a and i will have a special guest
for each show which will be revealing
some of them over the next couple weeks
but i would like to tease you with a few
of them you may have heard of this
dennis pragerfella he'll be joining me
in brea california so he'll do a little
intro and the q a
megan kelly will be joining me in west
nyack new york
megan mccain will be joining me right
there in the swamp in washington dc a
woman who survived being on the view i
mean my god does anyone deserve a round
of applause glenn beck my buddy glenn
beck will be joining me in dallas texas
benny johnson will be joining in
clearwater florida and we think we're 90
sure this one's happening and i think if
i say it aloud then that'll force the
universe to make it happen uh larry
elder should be joining me in oxnard
california and then we're going to add a
whole bunch of people to the other shows
and it's just going to be a blast and
i'm looking forward to to seeing you
guys shaking hands meeting greets
throwing t-shirts into the crowd
all kinds of crazy stuff meanwhile how's
my how's the shirt today right before we
went live there was a question if my
shirt was too open and then phoenix goes
ah it's friday don't worry about it so
friday it's a little more open than
usual uh got a big show for you today
uh these people that we often talk about
on the show these fouchies these bidens
sakes pelosi's etc i have come to the
belief that none of them can say
anything true that we're actually at the
point where they have crossed the
rubicon of insanity and they simply
cannot utter one statement that is true
so we're going to talk about all of them
but mostly fouchy in the first segment
and rand paul
who the great libertarian senator from
kentucky uh he is making sure that fauci
is going to be pushed out and he's doing
everything he can it's an uphill battle
obviously in the senate to get rid of
fouchy but rand paul's doing everything
he can and fauci of course wants more
mandates to come back so we're going to
play some clips on that then really the
big story of the week
is what should have been a big story
about a year and a half ago before the
election but it turns out that the
hunter biden laptop is legit now we all
knew it was legit it was very obvious it
was legit the way it was being silenced
on twitter and in mainstream media made
it more obvious that it was legit well
finally the new york times has admitted
it's legit and uh we're now gonna show
you some juxtaposition of what these
news outlets and pundits and blue check
people were saying uh back then versus
what they are saying now
and then finally the third segment the
democrats want to destroy america so
that's the big show today
i don't need to really explain that one
to you do i i don't think so all right
here we go so first up uh anthony fauci
the man who for the last two years has
been sort of the unelected king of the
united states who has lied repeatedly
who has
poured endless misinformation onto all
of us who has privately told people that
masks don't work while telling people
publicly to double mask while always
fudging the numbers while pushing for
lockdowns that we now don't work but no
don't work wanted vaccine mandates which
are now being repealed all of the
nonsense he has lied
about everything i don't know what
drives him perhaps other than power i
really don't uh but now that covid seems
to be going away and we're on to the new
season of war uh he's thinking about
bringing it back
and he was asked about what could happen
and yeah he's thinking about the
restrictions again we have to be careful
that if we do see a surge as a result of
that
that we're flexible enough to
reinstitute the kinds of interventions
that could be necessary to stop
an additional surge that could mean a
return of mandatory masking especially
in areas of high transmission
no
no no no no no no no you freak no more
masks
no more mandates no more passports this
thing is starting to get behind us and i
have no doubt that you guys want to
bring it back
there's just no doubt and i sense you'll
really bring it back in the fall right
before the midterm elections and you'll
try to freak everybody out get everybody
doing mail and balloting uh mailing you
know voting and all that stuff okay fine
no more of this nonsense you can wear a
mask if you want to wear a mask there is
no evidence that anything that you
people did
worked and i just i just don't
understand
to be in the mind of someone that that
actually could hear anthony fauci now
and be like boy
you know maybe he's right maybe we will
need more forced control from the
government maybe that guy deserves a
little more of our respect and a little
more patience and time to get this thing
right if any of the stuff that you said
worked actually worked then this
wouldn't have been two years after two
weeks to flatten the curve no foucher
you're an evil controlling authoritarian
maniac and thankfully i live here in the
free state of florida but if you live in
a blue state and they start bringing
this [ __ ] back
leave
but don't come here if you're not going
to vote the right way i really mean that
do not come to florida
and i will discuss privately with the
governor my situation where
i'm you know looking for moats that
we're going to put around houses with
the gators we're going to get the iron
domes from israel we're going to keep
people out
but you are welcome here if you want to
come here and fight for freedom and
fight for liberty and fight for american
principles and to keep states
independent but if you live in a state
where they're gonna listen
to anthony fauci
and if you think that anthony fauci is
worth listening to at this point i don't
know what to tell you
but a guy you should be listening to is
senator rand paul he is basically trying
to make sure that fauci will not have
any influence going forward
well tomorrow we'll have a health
committee meeting and there'll be a bill
presented and i will present an
amendment that will get a vote on
eliminating anthony fauci's position i
think we should eliminate his position
divided into three and appoint three new
directors that will be approvable by the
senate the problem with having only one
person and having everything go before
him for like 40 years is that he has
monopolized power and he's created a
culture that's not conducive to
scientific inquiry you need people who
question that's what science is about
it's about questioning and putting forth
your your hypothesis and then trying to
prove it with experiments but he's shown
dr fauci and dr collins have both shown
that they they're they they'll get into
the mud if you don't agree with their
political opinions they'll go after you
that's why the last time i had an
exchange with dr foucho we asked him
about some emails between him and dr
collins and in the emails he says let's
do a dramatic takedown of three
scientists who they disagreed with
politically well when a person like dr
fausti controls five billion dollars
worth of money it's not good that we
have a really petty tyrant who wants to
take down the people he disagrees with
and that's not conducive to scientific
inquiry so it's long past time that we
remove him from government
you know the thing i've been saying a
lot about how when someone's telling the
truth you kind of know they're telling
the truth and when someone's lying
or fudging it you know they're fudging
it well fauci if you listen to him from
a moment ago just oh we may have to do
the thing again and he doesn't give any
evidence as to why
it would work or whether it did work in
the past or anything else
compare that to rand paul talking about
science and what scientific inquiry is
all about and talking about the
monopolization
of power and the idea that this one man
simply has too much power i think you
could argue that even if he was doing a
good job even if you're not
sitting in the same exact position that
i'm sitting in which is that he's been a
complete fraud and a disaster for the
last two years even if you say okay well
he he sort of did an okay job why should
one man have so much power in a way not
only is he unelected but have so much
power over administration to
administration right he was working for
the trump administration now he's in the
biden administration um at this point
why wouldn't you just say all right
let's split up some of his power so
that's what rand paul is calling for
three different positions that would all
be confirmed by the senate and that way
they would be able to make independent
uh decisions related to health and covet
and all of those things so
who knows what the senate's gonna do the
senate usually doesn't do the right
thing you know and it's a little hard to
say how much power rand paul actually
has in the senate because we have so
many especially the
virtually all of the democrat side i
mean they just they just love the
lockdowns they love government power so
hopefully rand paul can get enough
republicans and maybe a maybe
there's a couple sane democrats in swing
states that are like uh you know the
people don't like this crap anymore so
we shall see what happens but man no
more no more you can't have any more the
only way this thing turns around is if
good people yes we can we can have
senators like rand paul trying to fight
the good fight but the only way this
thing actually ever turns around because
i guarantee you even though it feels
like we're getting this little reprieve
on covet right now they are bringing it
back that is not
a conspiracy theory there will be covid
2
or they will there will be the unicron
variant whatever whatever it is the
megatron the star scream the sound wave
optimus prime the whole shebang it's
coming back and we need to make sure
right now
right now that we are not going to play
this game again so
that's all i have to say about that the
big story this week of course though was
that the hunter biden laptop
which we were told was misinformation we
were told it was russian disinformation
we were told that you can't tweet about
it on twitter or post about it on
facebook the new york post which is one
of the oldest newspapers in the united
states was banned on twitter
when they broke the story originally and
of course they broke the story about a
month before the election and it was
very relevant to the election because it
had well there were all sorts of
pictures on there but there was also
emails from hunter biden related to his
dealings in ukraine and the money he was
getting as a consultant for barisma an
energy company there you think any of
this is relevant right now as we've got
this russia ukraine situation going on
we were all told we were conspiracy
theory theorists if we talked about it
people were banned suspended the whole
damn thing uh it was there was a
constant push that even if you said
anything about it or even remotely said
maybe we should think about it that you
were a russian agent and the whole thing
well
ladies and gentlemen turns out
it was true
all of it yeah it was true the laptop
the emails the pictures the whole
shebang all true
and it's so true that even
the new york times
all the news that's fit to make up
even they have had to acknowledge that
it is true here's the piece from the new
york times the key part of the story in
the new york times from two days ago
people familiar with the investigation
said prosecutors had examined emails
between mr biden mr archer and others
about burisma and other foreign business
activity those emails were obtained by
the new york times from a cachet of
files that appears to have come from a
laptop abandoned by mr biden in a
delaware repair shop which is exactly
what everyone was saying a year and a
half ago
the emails and others in the cachet
were authenticated by people familiar
with them and with the investigation in
some of the emails mr biden displayed a
familiarity with pharah and a desire to
avoid triggering it okay so let's really
just sit with this for just a second
this thing which a year and a half later
we are being told is true that could
have completely
changed the course of the election
uh was something we were not allowed to
talk about a year ago now why don't we
connor you did some fine work this
morning can we put up some of the things
that the mainstream media and the blue
check people were saying about it so on
the right you have the new york times
thing okay i just read that to you on
the left we're just going to show you
things that they these people and these
news organizations were saying back then
to me this is cnn to me this is just
classic textbook soviet russian
tradecraft at work former director of
national intelligence james clapper says
as authorities are investigating if
recently published emails are tied to
russian disinformation effort targeting
biden so james clapper made that up and
is a liar a russian disinformation npr
said why haven't you seen any stories
from npr about the new york post hunter
biden story read more in this week's
newsletter and then of course there's
the quote we don't want to waste our
time on stories that are not really
stories and we don't want to waste the
listeners and readers time on stories
that are just pure distractions you this
is where you have to have some sympathy
for all the blue pilled npc non-playable
character democrat voting morons you
have to because they've swallowed this
thing holy and by the way the cognitive
dissonance they're not going to accept
or even know what's happened now because
obviously mainstream media isn't going
to fully embrace this story now because
it would show that they were liars the
entire time i think we've got more from
that racist crazy lady over on msnbc joy
reid good for joe biden no need to
dignify a russian hatchet job strain
through rudy's utter brokenness with a
response we're not doing emails again
america 18 days just vote and ignore the
nonsense 18 days yeah 18 days and ignore
the nonsense the nonsense that turned
out to be true and by the way rudy was
given the laptop and yeah okay lady
politico back then more than 50
more than 50 former senior intelligence
officials have signed to a letter
outlining their belief that the recent
disclosure of emails allegedly belonging
to joe biden's son has all the classic
earmarks of a russian information
operation boy
the russians
must by giving us the truth
well i don't know what the russians are
doing this is very very confusing here's
this guy kyle griffin who's i think a
former msnbc clown another blue checker
no one should link or share to that new
york post report you can discuss the
obvious flaws and unanswerable questions
in the report without amplifying what
appears to be disinformation look how
many likes and retweets and all that
here's ben rhodes who used to work at
the obama administration who's been
wrong about absolutely everything and
would love it if iran had a nuke the
republican freak out over not being able
to spread disinformation unchecked
demonstrates why you should not be able
to spread disinformation unchecked they
know they have no political viability
with the without the capacity to spread
lies by his own words he should be
banned by twitter because he is a
misinformation specialist and wrong
about everything always but just he is a
liar he is a liar these people all knew
that they all somehow knew right how did
they know
that this thing was misinformation it
now of course they didn't want the
information to get out so that's how
they knew
but they didn't really know it's just
extraordinary and by the way there are
probably ten thousand i am not kidding
you ten thousand other examples of that
easily there there literally could be
hundreds of of examples of people on
twitter and all over the place but i
mean major people you can get thousands
of other examples of that none of those
people will be punished none of those
people will be fired none of those
people will be called out none of them
will be suspended
but the truth was suspended a year and a
half ago and did that change the
election i don't know and by the way the
most important piece of this
the most important piece of what
happened a year and a half ago is why
did twitter especially facebook did it
too but why did twitter
ban the new york post account and
suspend people for talking about this
how did that meeting happen at twitter
who was in charge was there a boardroom
meeting was there a policy meeting was
there a lawyer's meeting who was in
charge of that meeting and did those
people what was the information they
used to decide to ban and suspend people
for posting something that now turns out
to be true did those people have any
connection to the democrats did they
have any connection to the biden
campaign like what was the policy if we
don't find that out we'll never get to
the truth and unfortunately i don't
think we'll find that out but it just
does tell you if you're on social media
we are playing a fixed game we are all
playing a fixed game where they can
control the information they can control
the algorithms and who sees what and
when they see it and what's true and
what's information misinformation and
everything else here's a
chronic
misinformation specialist and liar in
chief jen sake on the hunter biden
report the new york times has
authenticated emails that appear to have
come from a laptop abandoned by hunter
biden in delaware um the president
previously said that the new york post
story about this was a bunch of garbage
and that it was a russian plant does he
stand by that assessment i appointed the
department of justice and also to hunter
biden's representatives he doesn't work
in the government go ahead
jen
i actually like what you did there did
you just uh refer the journalists to the
department of justice about this
situation because i don't know how
corrupt they are at this point i don't
know if there's anything left over there
but maybe they should be looking into it
because you know you just got caught
lady
here's joe biden a little bit before the
election saying how the whole thing is
nonsense and i really really want you to
listen to it because it's not just that
he says it's nonsense but guess who he
blames you're not going to believe it so
what about the americans who really
today only want me to ask you about
hunter biden's laptop how are you going
to get them
to see
that you are fighting for them when
they're so
against you
there's nothing to any of that
nothing to that it's all a smear
every major outfit every serious
investigator has pointed out
that this is a smear
this is classic trump
we have four days left and all of a
sudden there's a laptop and you may
recall there's also talk about four
months before there was a similar thing
that somebody had allegedly
there's overwhelming evidence that from
the intelligence community that the
russians are engaged i mean look this is
my son's an honorable man
and all the investigations that were
done around the issue of what was going
on in ukraine if you notice
every one of the major people who work
for trump
during the impeachment went under oath
and under oath said biden did his job
no law was providing this biden did his
job hunter biden broke no laws that was
the testimony
their testimony from republicans and
intelligence community people
god he has a mind muddled [ __ ] he
really is and that's a depressing
statement to say i wish the president of
the united states even if he had
policies that i did not this that i did
not agree with i wish
that he was in better shape than that
man but i want to point out to a couple
things he said there first of you know
nothing here is true it's all a smear
blah blah blah every major outlet and
our intelligence services are saying
that well that's the problem that's the
problem because there seems to be
collusion between our intelligence
services and the experts and then
mainstream media they just parrot all
the stuff it's it's a shell game it's a
it's a funneling of lies through the
entire system so yes you're right about
that joe but that's the problem in the
first place and then of course he blames
trump as if trump had something to do
with this that trump somehow created
this laptop situation and the emails and
all that and uh russians are engaged ah
yes so are you saying russians meddled
with the election and tried to get trump
elected because if you did
say that and even if it didn't come to
pass wouldn't you be doing something
about that right now
god they lie about everything i mean
this is close to impeachment level stuff
right so that him what he just said
there i mean basically blaming trump
lying about the laptop
i mean i get it that it was done before
he was president but the whole
presidency now seems to be based on a
lie the whole presidency seems to be
based on a lie on top of the fact that
the presidency in the year plus
of his administration has been a
horrific disaster
by far the worst in my lifetime and i
think many people could argue this might
be the worst administration
in american history
in american history this might be worse
than carter this might be worse than
some of the others a long time back
everything seems to be collapsing they
seem to be intentionally destroying the
the system and they seem to want to
usher in their great reset their new
world order whatever it is but please
show me something that joe biden is
doing that is pro-america that that is
helping ordinary americans and actually
that's a great segue to segment three i
believe the democrats are intentionally
destroying america here's joe biden on
uh inflation and what causes it and what
doesn't cause it
so i'm sick of this stuff
[Applause]
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money
simply not true
by simply not true he means true he
means totally
absolutely true
the government has a certain amount of
money where does the government get that
money it gets it from taxes so then
there's a certain amount of money now we
already have a huge amount of debt so
when we get money we don't have a
surplus of money we just have
potentially a little less debt but of
course with the interest rates and
everything else we're always just
driving ourselves into more debt that's
why the national debt grows literally
every day and it grows by i don't know
probably grows by hundreds of millions
of dollars every half hour or something
we figure out how fast it grows like how
much more debt are we in from when i
start this show every day to when i end
this show let's figure out give me
something on roughly how quickly this
thing is growing there's got to be some
calculator online somewhere with a very
very long number that's going to
ultimately crash the internet
the idea that when the government just
makes up money just prints more money
literally it's just imaginary based on
nothing throws it into the economy the
idea that that has nothing to do with
inflation or increasing the debt or
screwing over our economy is completely
insane it's completely insane it has
nothing to do with reality has nothing
to do with basic economics and is an
absolute lie and that's why when
i'm sick of it
that's why he's pretending to have human
emotion because that's what they're
really good at right he whispers
sometimes to say certain things and i'm
sick of that thing he's doing it all
based on fake emotion because the
reality of the policies is what is
destroying things if he is literally
sitting in a room
at the big
you know
he's in the oval office they got the two
yellow couches and the little coffee
table and he's at his desk and they got
all the people in there and if he's
sitting in a room with 15 people and
they're all like yes yes put more money
into the economy print more money it
won't cause any inflation it won't do
anything bad to the economy then all of
those people should be fired or should
be examined mentally for not
understanding basic i think seventh
grade
economics something like that
it never ends with these clowns here's
elizabeth warren she is a fake native
american who is a senator up in
massachusetts saying that inflation has
nothing to do with the policies that
they're pushing nothing to do with these
people it's a whole bunch of other
people their problems simple question to
you is what causes it and if i were to
read a lot of what you've said and
written
i would leap to the conclusion that you
think the primary cause of it is
corporate greed whether it's the oil
companies whether it's software
companies whether it's food processing
companies what causes inflation so i
think the primary cause of this bout of
price increases starts with coving
but what has also happened is that now
that we live in america where there's a
lot more concentration in certain
industries
look at the oil industry look at
meat industry look at groceries
generally
that what's happened is these companies
have said
you know we'll pass along costs but
while we're at it and everyone's talking
about rising costs let's just add an
extra big dollop
of cost increases to expand our profits
liz
okay first off none of this was
happening under the orange man okay so
you people took power your stupid
socialist ideas took over and that's
when the [ __ ] started to hit the fan so
was it suddenly that when they got rid
of orange man and mr mental [ __ ] took
over suddenly the meat packing people
were like yes let's really push it now
and increase the cost of hamburgers
because we got rid of trump it's
complete nonsense the people that are
pushing all of the [ __ ] on you and
who are lying about everything and
causing inflation causing you to spend
more on basic goods causing gas prices
to go up causing hamburger meat to cost
more and everything else are blaming the
people who produce those things do you
understand that they're blaming the very
people who produce those things in a
capitalist society where there is
competition to drive those costs down
but then when the government comes in
pumps a whole bunch of money and money
becomes worthless inflation starts going
up and then the companies are like boy
we're looking at our margins right now
and we have to start charging more
because we're not making as much money
she is a liar
she's a liar and a buffoon
yeah the meat people i love it the me
it's the meat people and it's the tech
people and the gas station people you
know there's nothing worse than a greedy
gas station owner
liar liar
fake native american i don't like you
and speaking of a woman i really don't
like here's aoc we have a crisis of
missing and um and murder indigenous and
black women in the united states
today i want to discuss part of this
crisis that is all too often overlooked
but whose evidence shows that there's a
very meaningful connection here the
correlation between fossil fuel
extraction sites and abductions and
murders of indigenous women across the
united states what the high hell do you
even want me to say about that what can
i even do with this i mean the woman is
purposely wearing big glasses to look
smart that's number one like she just
puts on the can i get the biggest
glasses possible the people are starting
to realize i'm an idiot
okay yes the big issue around fossil
fuels is something related to black
women and and indigenous people being
kidnapped or something like that these
people they are such unserious clowns
it's extreme i have nothing else to say
about that clip here's more on aoc she
did a little little was this a tick
tick-tock or an inside i think it's an
instagram video
she's doing the biden whisper thing now
which is even creepier than when he does
it tell you a secret
most people don't really know what
capitalism is
most people don't even know what
socialism is
but most people are not capitalists
because they don't have capitalist money
they're not billionaires sometimes the
label doesn't matter as much as just
talking about policies that's easier to
understand
do you think people should die because
they can't afford insulin
do you think that fossil fuel ceo should
decide whether the planet gets set off
fire
meanie
c word c word that's what she is but i'm
not gonna say it i'm not gonna say it
but that's what she is she is a liar she
is a full-blown socialist in our
government um and she is lying about
what capitalism is the idea that you
have to be a billionaire to be a
capitalist i want you everybody watching
this right now everyone in this room
gentlemen in this room could we all
think about our grandparents for a
second and our great grandparents who
all came here from different places
whether they came from eastern europe or
whether they came from north africa
or whether they came from canada or
anywhere else the story of america is
people who basically came with nothing
came through ellis island or came
through some other border came with
nothing but a dream that there was a
place of freedom that was based on
capitalism the idea that if you work
hard
that the government will get out of your
way enough so that you can live freely
and that is the greatest
excuse me that is the greatest dream
just a sec having a hillary clinton
moment
[Laughter]
um that is the greatest dream
that probably has ever happened in the
history of the world and she wants to
destroy that these people came here with
nothing then you had an idea i'd like to
open up a restaurant
i'd like to
sell rubber bands i'd like to
whatever literally anything and you can
do it here and there's still a chance to
do it here and that's why we're still
the envy of the world and that's why
these socialists never leave
so she's a liar she's a socialist it's
an embarrassment that she's part of the
government
and uh
we got to vote these people out so that
we can end this national nightmare that
we are part of they are trying to upend
the economy they are trying to ruin the
thing
that is the greatest thing because they
hate the thing because they think they
own the world and they do not they do
not but if we give it to them they will
that's where we're at uh we got a funny
video related to the aoc thing that
we're going to do a cold close with but
before we do that i just want to remind
you guys that the don't burn this
country book
tour well first if you want to just buy
the book straight up old school people
the book is out on april 12th and you
can go to davereuben.com
book and order the book right now and
the tour
tickets are on sale right now orlando
west palm clearwater florida raleigh
north carolina atlanta georgia chicago
illinois dallas texas washington dc west
nyack new york brea california oxnard
california san jose california phoenix
arizona denver colorado and we're going
to get some great guests to join us i
mentioned dennis prager in brea i think
we've got larry elder for oxnard we've
got megan kelly for
west nyack we've got megan mccain for
d.c we've got benny johnson for
clearwater we've got glenn beck for
dallas and i'll be adding some more
people throughout the weeks and it's
going to be fun we're going to mess
around with the crowd i'm going to throw
t-shirts out to you good people and
maybe we'll give away mugs and other
things there'll be hugs and smiles and
drinking and good times i hope you will
join us so again it's davereuben.com
events and then you can find all of the
links
right over there
and uh to end the show this will be a
cold close we put together a little
something
in honor of miss a
o c
[Music]
most people don't really know what
capitalism is
most people don't even know what
socialism is
but most people are not capitalists
because they don't have capitalist money
they're not billionaires the label
doesn't matter as much as just talking
about policies that's easier to
understand
do you think people should die because
they can't afford insulin no
you got their own house